these are coherent mini progressions and
you don't wanna take a stab why gp's are
cold GPS
what's geometric all of these they're
all ballad I will give you what as far
as I know is the historical reason okay
clearly of all the APS and GPS that are
out there some are more special than
others right so for instance some really
really important a PNG people if you
have a look at this so what's happening
here right if all GPS had this kind of
behavior right how would you describe
what's happening as you go from term to
term okay well in a real way like okay I
know we're saying this is generally I n
minus 1 but particulars because they
can't so often they have particular
names right no one reads this is a r ^ 2
and no one reads this is AR the past
race unless you're in geekier than I am
right
in fact you say AR swing and a are huge
now that's how we stop the reason why we
stopped and we don't have a special
mainly really fits it has is because we
live in every cannon three dimensions
right so why would you represent each of
these spatially this would be like a
point this guy would be like a line the
next one is a square right and once you
get through the next one it'll be our
cue ball also known by its much cooler
Avengers related name a tesseract
busiest relationship here but the the
fact that this is growing in a clearly
geometric way right these are shapes
that we're talking about that's
basically the reason why this Accord
gp's and it doesn't it's not that bad my
dear actually to think of it as
something alive and Square and energy
because that's really my foot are
algebraically that's what's happening
okay so that's a little side note okay I
hope the picture stays with you so look
at this question this question is not
much of a question at the moment because
right now in fact the reason why I have
left it so vague is because we're gonna
do two things with them three terms are
enough to define of progression right
three times I know but when you don't
know what the three terms are this
sequence could be anything right it
could be and I've got rid of it cuz I
need the space this could be an AP or it
could be a GP or it could be depending
on what the value of x is okay so in
fact we're gonna do both of them we're
gonna make this thing into an AP a
certain value of x will make metric and
then we're gonna make a GP with a
different value of x
sorry you broke it on now because your
brain is in GP mode at the moment at
this second let's say the GP folks
they've known all of you she gave you a
clue so how would we make this sequence
here how would we make it a GP and the
fact is we know exactly what makes a GP
a GP
it's a coloration how do you test for a
common ratio now this is the way we
would check when there are sequences in
a GP or not right now I am Telling You
all rather red defining we're saying
yeah I'm making it a GP we're saying
it's a GP therefore this is true as
opposed to when you're testing you don't
know whether this is true or not
you don't know where visit to quality
which is why you do white and then you
do the other completely different link
so we know it's a GP we're locking it in
so now therefore being let me know what
term 1 2 & 3 are let's just put them in
and see what happens okay so I've got to
turn one oh I know this to be true if in
fact it is a GP ok and from here is not
that difficult
what am I going to get out of this this
amounts to solving what kind of equation
it's a quadratic isn't it I ain't X plus
16 you happy with that
check out of course I want to value of x
right so if I am just meeting this up a
little bit I'll bring everything in the
left-hand side I'm gonna subtract 3x
that gives me 5 I'm gonna go take away
30 right which leaves me with minus 14
that checking out
you happy with that factorize for weeks
now unsurprisingly as we should have
predicted the second week route down the
quadratic there are two solutions right
there's x equals negative 7 or x equals
2
okay now let's just see what happens
right because now I have these values I
can put them back in my original
sequence right let's get the first one
ago 3 so this is Algy
this is GP one I suppose number one the
first GP is going to look like this 3 is
always the first term what's the second
term t minus 3 because it's minus 7 plus
4 right and then we'll do minus 7 plus
10 that's positive 3 right
is this a GPS yeah you bet it is a is
equal to 3 and R is equal to negative 1
and if the Knicks are sending me minus 3
and then 3 and then and so on so this
worked let's check out GP number 2 at
least what we're hoping it is the first
term is still 3 what's the second time
suit seeks and then the third term does
it check out sure does common ratio of 2
years that's the GP I think I gave you
the question 1 ok now that's what
happens if there's a GP we start with
this it's not function as a test anymore
because we're not testing we're saying
it's a GP what am I going to start with
for an AP
so this is the condition for something
that's an AP so if I am defining it as
an AP then I can just state that all
right so let's give this about X plus 10
what's your signs you happy with that
don't we turn to ten to ten one okay
it's what kind of equation what kind of
family is belong to this is a quadratic
this is video all right video why is it
that you then getting one out of the
yeah think about it for second what am I
going to get on this left hand side x is
cancelled I just get 40 sorry
No six is a minus sign on the right hand
side so X is equal to Y so let's test it
out what's this ap gonna look like first
terminal 3 second term does it check out
it had been up because that's where we
started right if it doesn't pass the
test we're done something right um why
is it why is it that there's only one
solution for the AP but there's two
solutions for the yeah because there's
this come a difference thing we can
think of in terms of these categories
are we clear
right you think about this if I've got
if I've got a let's think an AP world
right I've got my first term define it
has to be positive right so it's one of
these it has to be 188 quite can't
possibly be I over these right here or
here but hold on a second hold on
last I checked whatever the value of X
is right whatever that in X is X plus 4
will always be I should set this way X
plus 10 will always be bigger than X
plus 4 do you agree with that so I can't
possibly be going in this direction I
can't get to [ __ ] here I can only be
going in one direction
so there boy there's only one
possibility but when you come down to a
GP you have a look right again my first
term is positive okay so it's either
this one this right is there anything
stopping me from alternate and well
obviously the answer is no okay nothing
like what I said before where this has
to be headed in a certain it has to be
getting bigger so completely this one
okay